welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz this is
another edition of the early on in
recruitment series where we're
uncovering and speaking to recruiters
who are early on in their recruitment
journey to find out
how they're getting on advice for people
that are considering recruiting as a
career get tips from them and how to
survive that actually absolutely smash
your first-year recruitment advice for
people to
do really well in their interviews for
recruitment
and a lot of other things but i'm really
excited to be joined by herman today
from ambition recruitment but before we
start uh before i start giving you loads
of questions and i was breaking this
down hey man if you could introduce
yourself
and uh we'll get into it
so my name's um harman
and been working in recruitment for
pretty much just two years bang on now
um graduated in
well finished my uni course in june 2019
and joined recruitment month after um
and i recruit into insolvency and
restructuring ambition
so have you had your graduation have you
had that yeah no i mean covered wasn't
the thing when i graduated that hit um
the march after of 2020.
some people haven't had that day i'm
sure you've had mates that might not
have had that yeah no
yeah there's a people that haven't had
that yet people who did masters um still
haven't actually had a ceremony yet
which is a bit cutting for them i'm sure
yeah it's not a deal is that so as you
said obviously graduating 2019
and you what
geography that you've got a degree in
yeah geography nice okay
um so
graduated that like let's just start
like how how the hell did you end up in
recruitment like was it did you have
mates in recruitment did you like i
don't know talk to us about that how did
you end up in recruitment um
so it was actually a cousin that
suggested it to me i must have got to i
don't know christmas or third year um
and i just had no clue what i wanted to
do um sort of sort of spoke to him about
it and i was like
god i'm graduating this summer no idea
what i want to do i mean geography's all
right i focused a bit like on the human
side geography but it wasn't really
my thing like i enjoyed the course but
the careers from it and i didn't really
fancy working as a town planner for the
council or whatever so
um sort of spoke to him about it and he
had suggested recruitment and i'd never
really i mean i knew what the word meant
but i didn't really know what what it
really is
yeah
so yeah i've sort of researched it um
sort of looked into it looked at a few
different companies um listened to your
podcast at the time as well um i think
it was called the recruitment
rollercoaster podcast back then um yeah
and just from the stories from that just
sort of spurred me on to actually go for
it um
so let's just let's just talk about
that pressure that you're feeling i
think it's important i think i didn't go
to university but i think we all
feel pressures of like what the hell
will we do with our life basically and
that constant
just feeling of like is this what i want
to do maybe the rest of my life or like
what my purpose is or whatever so like
would you mind just talking a bit about
that because i feel like i'm sure you've
spoken about this with your friends but
that's
a lot of pressure right you've gone to
university there's debt that you've
taken on and i'm sure you've had you've
got parent pressure as well like
like harman what are you doing like
so like how did you process that out of
interest like maybe even a bit with a
bit of hindsight for people that might
be going through that now but talk to us
about how you felt and how you're
processing and dealing with that
pressure um
i guess i mean a lot of people probably
turn to google these days don't they um
and just sort of google what to do if
you don't know what you're gonna do um
after graduation so i turned to google
um you know watched a few youtube vids
and stuff and everyone said oh don't
stress you'll find your own path in life
just choose what you enjoy whatever um
yeah and hearing that as someone that
doesn't know what they want to do you
just wish that someone could just give
you the answer um
so it's annoying that i'm gonna say this
but i think just choose something which
you think you're gonna enjoy in fairness
um try not to stress about it even
though that's
that's not gonna help me to saying that
um i think okay yeah the best thing you
can do is i mean you know reach out to
um if you've got any sort of older mates
that have graduated or you know
brothers sisters cousins you know maybe
your parents
um just for an idea of what to do um
yeah like there's there's no pressure on
like you're not gonna
chances are you know your first job
you're not gonna retire in um yeah you
know graduating at 21 like i guess
you've got your whole life ahead of you
so there's no stress to pick the perfect
career just choose something you think
you're gonna be
you know half good at
give it a go if you do well you do well
if you don't then learn from it choose
something else kind of thing
yeah i think for me it was like a
massive pressure of
oh it's gotta be you know the exact
thing i'll be doing for the rest of my
life um yeah i've gotta be perfect at it
i mean luckily it's worked out for me in
recruitment but
um i think yeah just try not to stress
about it really do your research
so let's just talk to that very quickly
and then we'll move on because i think
that's actually it's that and like this
is what i've taken from some of these
conversations which i just find
fascinating really like
this idea that like you're going to find
exactly what you want to do in the
perfect job like straight out the back
like straight out of the gate do you
know what i mean yeah but if i think my
i had no idea what i wanted to do and i
then ended up stumbling into sales
but before that i was doing all sorts of
delivering pizzas for dominoes working
at bq working in different things
then i went abroad had to get i got a
sales role whereas commission only then
i was like oh sales it was really
difficult to start but i enjoyed it and
then that was that but like
could you talk to that a sec like for
anyone that's feeling right now that
they like why is it why like i don't
know i guess it's easier for you to feel
like that now because i don't know like
just why how can we help people
just not put so much weight to i have to
get the perfect job
like the first job out of uni
um
i think
i think that's doing just doing your
research i mean people who are watching
this you know you can take from it you
know
me just saying it's not particularly
going to help um but if you just do your
research speak to people that have
graduated
um yeah and from their stories you'll be
able to tell it will give you a bit more
confidence in yourself that you're
choosing the right thing or it's it's
not a massive commitment um yeah yeah at
the end of the day um
you know once you've graduated you might
want to take a gap year or whatever if
you want do some traveling um or you
might want to you know start earning
straight away um so i guess you know
there really isn't any pressure i guess
the only real pressure is you know just
your degree focus on the degree more
than anything get a decent you know get
a 2-1 get it first if you can um that's
the main thing really um you know in
your spare time just look around for
jobs um
something which you think you know you
would find interesting i think the main
thing is you know go for some interviews
um meet the people that actually work
there um and ask the questions there you
know go for interviews what i tell my
candidates is it's not a commitment to
taking the job
you know it's just a fact fight you know
you're interviewing them as much as
they're interviewing you
so yeah yeah just try not to stress
relax
yeah no good point and i think just and
then it'd be good to get your thoughts
on this but i think the other thing just
to like really
sort of underline is like
definitely don't don't definitely don't
like put a lot of weight on how your
cv's gonna look as well
i mean like if you're going to a job and
you're like three months in
and you're like this is [ __ ] terrible
like i do not want to be doing this and
then you get another job like that isn't
going to affect your chances in 10 years
10 10 years time to get a job do you
know what i mean even in the short term
i think sometimes as well like people
like i don't know obviously you help
people now prep blah blah blah like if
you
don't if you have a couple of client um
businesses on your cv and you're just
graduated like that's not the end of the
world like you're gonna be experimenting
and finding stuff out yeah i think the
key thing with that is i guess people
are afraid of being too jumpy um yeah
i mean it's i guess i don't know i've
only been recruiting for two years so i
can't really speak
for how it used to be from what i've
heard though um it's getting better with
with clients talking about cds being
jumpy they understand that people who
are a bit younger are going to move
around
every couple years or you know a couple
months maybe um depending on how the
firm
sort of treated them really or how they
sort of felt they fit in so i think the
key thing here is if you can get your
foot in the door and interview just
explain the reasons why they're probably
going to ask you even if they're sort of
fairly understanding if you've been to
three different firms in a year um
that obviously you know logically that's
going to raise
some
actually they're going to want to know
why just make sure you've got answers
ready for that um if they're genuine and
you know
um you know boss was you know didn't
really get along with it or it wasn't
the right fit for you just explain it i
mean you know logical rational um
partner director will understand that i
think
yeah yeah i think yeah i think just
final point on this i think as well i
think what would make if yeah i get i'll
get that but i think if you're it's
different if you're jumping within one
industry compared to different
industries do you know what i mean
because it's quite a logical story where
it's like okay over the last 12 24
months i've worked at four different
companies but
two like two um companies with different
sectors so i've worked out that wasn't
right for me but yeah it's definitely
you're gonna have to have a solid story
if it's constantly jumping around in one
industry do you know what i mean yeah
yeah definitely yeah
so
cool so the question i have first then
so obviously it seems like recruitment
really impedes your curiosity
ended up in recruitment but like what
i'd be keen to know from you is what
skills or experiences recruitment given
you that you least expected
um
it's a difficult one i think um because
you have such a different you have no
idea well you have a bit of an idea but
not as much of an idea of what
recruitment actually entails when you
first join as to when you've been doing
it for a little while um yeah so i
didn't know that you know everyone says
it's fast paced you know you've got to
be resilient and all these different
things but you just sort of say yeah
yeah that's fine i'm resilient i can't
do all this stuff
yeah you've actually got no idea um it's
actually tough so i think the main thing
i
the main thing the main skill i think
i've learned and something which i'm
still sort of developing um probably is
just prioritizing tasks in order of
in order of importance so you might have
you know
x number of jobs come through the door
um or you might be working with a number
of candidates you've got to be able to
rank it in order of what's going to get
you where you want to be essentially or
what's going to be
um i think knowing when to quit is is is
one of the most important things that's
been something that's difficult um
you know if you've if you've been trying
to source a job for quite a long time
the client's tricky or
you know the processors are dragging or
you're sending candidates and they're
just not getting the interview that you
know the client might be really really
choosy
your time is probably best spent
elsewhere
so i think yeah prioritizing jobs um is
a key skill but i didn't realize i'd get
and i guess that sort of spills over
into life as well if you've got a lot of
time management prioritizing yeah time
management yeah yeah time management i
mean yeah i mean i remember sort of
talking about an interview being like
yeah time management i've got like that
i've got all these deadlines to hit but
you've only got maybe what one two three
assignments to do at a time and at uni
you've got all the time in the world
haven't you getting up for like one um
and then just doing a bit of work you
know going out and then just doing it
where you can few all nighters maybe
here and there um so
i think um yeah
yeah definitely the spinning plates part
of it prioritizing tasks that's probably
the least expected skills i think i've
got from it even though i was told that
i'd need that
yeah yeah i know it's different in
reality isn't it when you actually yeah
exactly
it's it's it's a really it's a really
common area this even for people that
are like
free four years down the track like time
management productivity is is definitely
because it isn't it isn't something that
it's like a in in the in the recruitment
mentors community it's like a it was a
new sort of learning development area
that we introduced like three four
months ago because it like we kept
getting feedback about that's an area
that people really want to develop or
improve in because you sort of just have
to stumble and learn the hard way really
like i mean that's what like there
wasn't really you don't really get a lot
of support on that or like training so i
guess my next question is and i know you
said you're still developing this but i
guess for people listening to this that
are in a similar spot to you i guess
what are some of the things that you do
now to get better at prioritizing out of
interest that maybe you didn't do at the
beginning or you had to learn the hard
way out of interest um
that's quite a difficult question uh
i think
i don't know i think it is
it depends on the individual some things
will work some people some things won't
work for others i use microsoft to do
the to-do list you can you know
prioritize it that's just a really like
um useful thing for me you can slide
it's not going to do this you can slide
tick it off when you've done it that's
our digital one yeah essentially yeah i
mean we did have training on it um
but and that was useful but i think a
lot of it's on the job does trial and
error what works for you um yeah work
closely with your manager be
self-critical um when things don't go
your way um and to sort of learn from it
i think the key from it is so cliche but
it's just learning from your mistakes
isn't it really yeah yeah yeah or at
least trying to improve on it
yeah have you this came out of one of
our training sessions recently and i
actually did this when i first launched
my own business when i started training
recruiters on personal branding and it
really helped because i had to really
there's just i'd obviously spun a lot of
places and recruitment but there's even
more plates
when you something when you start your
own business if it's just you but
something have you have you ever looked
at like basically auditing a week
or like your desk out of interest so an
exercise i did that you might find
useful people listening is basically so
for a whole week what i did i was
working with a coach at the time to
recommend dinner so basically for a
whole week every single hour you write
down what you did
and the reason why that'll be useful is
because you'd be surprised the amount of
time you spend on certain things
so you might be thinking yeah i'd
recommend doing that because that's
actually that's i'll try that
next try
yeah one whole week so every single hour
if i've got terrible handwriting so i
did it digitally so like every single
hour or if obviously if you do different
things in that hour you just write down
every single hour what did i do blah
blah blah
and
you'd be surprised there might be some
areas like how why the hell am i
spending that much time on this or yeah
this is where i need to so
yeah i get that and i know it's very
much on the job and learning what works
for you but i wanted to ask so the next
thing then
spoke around things that yeah maybe
you've gained that you didn't um expect
what have been obviously i'm sure
you got this from the podcast when you
listen but obviously everyone will say
recruitment early on is just so so
difficult so what have been some of the
challenges that you've had to
work through out of interest so far um
so i guess challenge i think yeah
spinning plates that is tough like that
is mentally draining um yeah trying to
spin plates when you've got you know
um targets to hit you know things drop
out like it is a tough job um
you know things don't always go your way
even if sometimes maybe you did
everything by the book um have you dealt
with that because that's harder the
bigger then
i mean it was never actually i mean i
guess at the time you're fuming if
something doesn't go your way
because you know you start talking up
the figures in your head and you think
wow this is going to be great you know i
i could potentially be top bit of this
month or whatever um and you pick
yourself up so i think for me
um
the key thing is i i never
get too excited until something is done
and dusted and the author's accepted
written that person's
maybe not started but that you know it's
pretty much done and does seem to put
the fee through the system that's when
you can sort of celebrate like early on
like my first fee
or one of my one of my first fees got
really really excited about it was my
biggest theme recruitment absolutely
buzzing told everyone um
you know and uh and then she accepted
the counteroffer um
so now i'm just a bit more relaxed about
it i think that's that's how i deal with
it
a bit more grounded like so you're not
too high
not too low yeah just just chill out um
and you know there's always going to be
peaks um and there's always going to be
loads as well so just take it how it
comes just accept it as part of the job
at the end of the day just do what you
can to mitigate it early on
um
and then if it's you know if it does go
wrong um
you're still going to be upset of course
just go for a walk chill out do whatever
you want to do um then come back discuss
it with your team
like you know i've got a great team
really supportive so you can just sort
of talk it over with them and see you
know if you did go wrong you know did
you talk about this this
um and you're just trying to eventually
trying to get that emotion sometimes out
of your system isn't it yeah yeah
instead of it letting it ruin the rest
of your day or the week or whatever
what about how have you mentioned
spinning a lot of plates again like how
have you found have you found it
difficult to switch off since you've
been in recruitment yeah um i'd say
about something i think is probably the
actually the most difficult thing about
the job of switching off actually really
um yeah especially when
because if you proper throw yourself
into it like like i have um
especially early on um
when i first started it was yeah 8 30
start 6 p.m finish
um
and then you know if you had something
on you'd be working late i live quite
far from london so it's about an hour
and a half there and back like someone's
getting high wake up at 6.
so that was tough um
but i think yeah um
it's a stiff question to answer how
would you
well you might you might not be i'm just
it's just good that you're talking about
it because there'll be people yeah
yeah i mean i think
yeah i think he's got it's cause it'll
have a work-life balance with it really
haven't you um
yeah one one thing that's i find i find
it hard to switch off but one of the
things that i don't know if you do this
but one of the things that's really
helped me and there'll be some weeks i'm
good at this some weeks i'm terrible but
most of the time i'm quite good at it
but
before i wouldn't like
close off the week and what i mean by
that is
so something that i do every single week
now most of the time is i'll basically
reflect um at the end of my week on
basically for like 45 minutes it's four
till 4 45 on a friday and i'll reflect
on okay what went well this week what
didn't and then i'll also then look at
my goals for the month quarter and then
think about the week ahead i think when
i really struggled to switch off was i
didn't like i didn't like have closure
on the week you know i mean when you
sort of go into the weekend or even the
evening sometimes when there's loose
ends you're thinking about certain
things because you haven't made it i
don't know you're already thinking about
next week do you know what i mean yeah
so i think that's definitely helped me
yeah the big the big time when it's a
struggle is when um when you go to bed
when you go to sleep and you stay and
then your mind's just rushing with stuff
like i should have done this should have
done that so that's that yeah that is
difficult i think that's like an ongoing
thing really trying to switch off um
but uh
yeah um i guess just uh
what you said yeah it's planning ahead
yeah that's why it's doing yeah whatever
you do that's a perfect answer no no
yeah i definitely wasn't doing that
early on but i wish i'd i've just
yeah i've had to really invest a lot
into like time management like since
having my own business and stuff like
i've just really had to do that because
there's no one else holding me
accountable do you know what i mean
besides myself
so i guess on that i would definitely if
you're not already and again this has
been a game changer for me but like if
you if you if you leave the office
without planning your the next day like
you will you will have even more of
those thoughts when you're before you go
to bed
so i don't know if you're doing that but
i would definitely encourage you to do
that mate yeah and i usually like before
before before leave the office try and
write like three main things need to do
first thing i think yeah anything i
guess i do that but not with the
relation not not with a view to sort of
switching off it's more just like a
so i'm not sort of scrabbling about
morning after trying to figure out our
goal without yesterday was yeah yeah
kind of thing which has helped with that
um yeah yeah that's a solid tip for
switching off as well i think
what about so with that then on this
because i think this is one of the
challenges with the recruiting industry
and why grads
come in the industry and then get spat
straight back out like how
and again you may not have an answer
this but we're talking about it's
important so like you said waking up
early
long commute working hard like what how
did you make sure you didn't get burnt
out
i did actually i mean you did yeah no i
mean i was
waking up at six
getting into the office and then
sometimes work until like you know
half seven um
just thought you know if i put in more
hours than anyone else or if i put you
know there are other competitors out
there and i could be doing this i'll be
able to get an edge i'll be you know
yeah i'll have fun
um but i think um
you can do it within the hours you said
obviously you might spill over i think
and
i think the key thing is just planning
planning your day um i think that audit
your week um
that's obviously a tip i've just got on
this call but that's that's
that sounds that sounds really good i'm
going to start off from next week just
to see where i'm spending your time but
i guess i sort of did that already just
sort of thinking
um
you know how's my time
best spent um you know don't call
candidates or clients just for the sake
of it get your numbers up yeah i
actually want good quality calls sit
back um review your desks you know
where you know where it's going to get
me to target the quickest or
i mean i was just working too many hours
i think i was just grinding out in the
office till late and then yeah i went to
the gyms down the road from the offices
um because um just because it's there um
and sometimes i wouldn't get home until
like you know 10 11 and
um that's just too much
but i don't work for jp morgan um
and i'm not trying to save the world
that's a bit extreme um so i mean i
still get the same amount of work done
um and i still might put pull the odd
you know late late one um or do a bit of
work you know
when i probably should be relaxing but i
think it's just a balance really um to
try and figure out what what works best
for you um what what like what i like
non-negotiables for you then out of
interest like now maybe that you think
helps you and look there will be some
weeks where you've got a great
opportunity you know that if you place
these three four jobs you're going to be
in a good spot so like you might end up
having a week where you're like just
absolutely slogging out that that's just
part of the game but like you said and
it's why we're having this conversation
it's not sustainable like you're not
going to have a successful career in
recruitment without it being sustainable
yeah habits that you're building stuff
so i guess just interesting for people
who listen to us that may have
experienced this already or might be in
the middle of it right now where they're
doing what you were doing it's
absolutely slugging it out but it's just
there's gonna there might be a point
where they're just like absolutely
knackered or they fall ill or whatever
like what's non-negotiable for you now
out of interest that i don't know maybe
every single week you put time to do x i
don't know maybe
maybe i thought i'd ask
i don't really do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean by non
negotiation but intentionally
that i will spend doing one thing or
well i guess sorry so i guess what i was
trying to find out was you said that
you've you felt like you've experienced
experience being burnt out yeah so i
guess i'm assuming after that you're
like right i'm going to stop like doing
this or i'm going to make sure i make
give myself time to do this that might
help you not be in that position again
do you know what i mean yeah so i need
to find out yeah i i guess um
i try to try and take breaks now i think
it's harder doing that from home i mean
in the office i usually used to take i
you know you just feel like a pop out to
you know whatever get a coffee and a
sandwich come back and work at the desk
you know go for a walk take take you
know at least half an hour 45 minutes
out of your day just to do something
that's not recruitment
um yeah
because it's and it's it's easy to sort
of work
you know way past the hours you probably
should be at home because you just wake
up
you straight at your desk like you're at
work
so yeah trying to try to take trying to
take a you know a little bit of time out
where you can um
lunch time yeah
so i try and do that that helps yeah
yeah that's really useful because it's
easy to you see people in the office
don't you just having their mildew in
front of their
desk put that in the bin and then
they're back slugging out again so
definitely you've separated that um
okay
so the next thing i know that you
thought this would have been really
useful for you to
think about or spend some more time on
so i wanted to ask it for you so let's
just talk a bit about for the next sort
of 10-15 minutes before we finish
um
like just advice for people maybe
considering recruitment and we'll talk a
bit about some other things but
what was your whole process on like
finding out what industry you wanted to
recruit and out of interest in uh
yeah yeah so that was a massive one for
me because i was sort of looking around
recruitment firms um you know what have
you got you got audit tax
um finance accounting all the tech all
this all this stuff and it's like what
on earth do i recruit into um and to be
honest i sort of just took a look at the
company's website i had a look at their
promo video whatever looked on glassdoor
for average salaries and that kind of
thing um and reviews and just sort of
applies and interviewed it places and
got a feel from it from that um i think
yeah in hindsight i was
you shouldn't really bother about it
that much it's not that important you go
for an interview i mean i interviewed
here so we recruit for um sort of
all the service lines for professional
services legal and practice um
had an interview um and i don't know how
many people are if it's so many people
but i can tell now they're all people
from the different teams
um and they sort of saw which which team
my personality fit into and you sort of
just get given the desk really don't you
yeah and then you learn more about that
industry
um you know how the candidates are how
the clients are um and go from there so
i don't think it's particularly anything
to be that worried about um just
interview as many places as you can
um and then just ask the question like
you know
why should i choose tech recruitment
over i don't don't presumptuous but you
know why do i choose this over this you
know
yeah yeah for sure okay
and what about then what would be your
advice for people
who i mean i've seen i saw another i
don't know if you've seen these but
like obviously it's it's difficult for
grads to enter the workforce right stand
out it's a lot of competition yeah and
see i mean i've seen those posts where i
saw a guy
this week post i don't know if you saw
it guys sitting in a free piece standing
in three-piece suit outside liverpool
street
yeah
[ __ ] roasting mate oh my god it's not
there
30 degrees yeah do you know what i mean
it's just like he wouldn't be doing that
if it was if it was like easy to get a
job do you know what i mean
so like advice for people listen to this
that i don't know knowing what you know
now
obviously you've prepped candidates
obviously it's not for you but how can
grad stand out do you think
um
i mean i wouldn't say you have to go to
the extreme of standing out on the
street corner with your cv and stuff
that probably didn't work for me i think
that post got like five yeah i'm sure
i'm sure yeah i'm sure i'm sure he's
probably got a few
interviews off the back of that so you
know if you back yourself do that go and
do it um
yeah
but um i think uh in terms of
you know getting yourself into processes
first of all choose what you want to do
or even if you don't know what you want
to do just apply to a variety of things
if it's recruitment um
i just used linkedin easy apply was nice
and easy uploaded cv bang bang bangs
applying to all these companies um get
some ideas off the back of that um i'd
say the key thing is yeah with the cv um
i don't know how important this is for
other other places but for me if i see a
cv that's not formatted correctly or the
content's got spelling mistakes that
doesn't annoys me um like it's you know
put a bit of effort into it double check
it and stuff
um that kind of thing and then when you
do get into an interview this is
obviously probably more important than
your cv um is to just prep as much as
you can in terms of research into the
company um but i'd say more importantly
the the people that are interviewing you
if you can find that out so if you're
going through um i don't know if you go
through a wreck to wreck they'll
probably tell you or if you're applying
directly um just ask the internal
recruiter or whoever you're speaking to
who are you interviewing with build a
bit of rapport with them um because a
lot of
um recruitment interviews and the highs
off the back of them are based on
personality really aren't they more than
anything yeah culture isn't it yeah so
student
yeah just build a bit of rapport with
them um i like pretty much stalked the
the director
ambition before right before i joined
and looked at everyone's profiles um you
know looked their likes found other
interests um so when you go in you can
you know shake their hand you know
address them by their name and that's
what kind of stuff really impresses um
yeah and then in your questions
um
just you know you might always have the
chance to um show you've done all this
research in the interview so at the end
if they ask you any questions you know
um
i you know
i saw that you did
i saw that you know i've seen you been
working here for 10 years kind of thing
you joined straight out of out of uni um
what advice would you have for me to be
successful or something like that that's
literally yeah that's literally one of
the questions i asked that i think that
some presses yeah yeah no for sure
so on this i think because just
again i didn't go to university but like
how how like was you like communicating
to like how powerful linkedin can be for
your career
not at all um
yeah i mean i sort of just got it as a
joke um in first year me and all my
mates have sort of downloaded linkedin
website like what is i think they did
business management a lot of them
had to make a linkedin profile for their
course maybe they studied something
about it on that but you can imagine in
geography
like i'm not i'm not i was linkedin was
not a part of my course at all which in
hindsight i mean yeah they'd probably
see it in schools to be fair um yeah
yeah
it's about his career isn't it it's like
it's correlated
why didn't you
what i wanted to ask you is again people
listen to this like so you said that
obviously use linkedin to apply but and
then you also use it for research but
anything else did you like how else did
you use linkedin when you were like
applying trying to get in the door with
places that maybe was also useful do you
think
um
i guess i mean i followed the hashtag
recruitment um
hashtag recruitment jobs followed all
that started liking internal recruiters
posts um
and i guess the engaging with people
yeah just engage with people you know
comment on stuff you know maybe do like
a post something like that i don't know
about your unique course just get some
engagement going um yeah if you can and
just apply to jobs doesn't have to be
through linkedin it can be through
the company's website it can be through
um you know read whatever um but with
linkedin i think um
key thing is just to
the way the algorithm works you just
want to you know post stuff like stuff
common stuff
and then your profile gets seen
yeah yeah for sure i think uh i think
one of the great things about linkedin
is like people generally are willing to
help on on the platform yeah literally
if if you regret listening to this and
you're like i i really want
help with this like literally i would
just do a post
stick a picture of yourself on there and
be like this is me this is what i'm
after anyone but if anyone could help
that would be great and you'd be
surprised i think people could help so
yeah definitely i i think yeah
linkedin's amazing um i think
i mean what do people do before linkedin
no idea yeah no
i just can't believe it's like not
actively spoken about yeah that's just
crazy
it's just nice
so a couple of things before we finish
so i know that obviously part of your
journey so far was when you was on
furlough
but what i wanted to ask you was
i guess i know like you're still on your
journey but just interested so like for
people that might be
still in their first year
like what would be your top tips for
success or to have the best chance of
having success
in recruitment in those first six twelve
months out of interest knowing what you
know um
i think you've got to fully commit to it
um
yeah you don't have to work crazy hours
but you probably will have to do
some unsociable hours at times just to
get stuff over the line um yeah
but aside from that i think yeah commit
yourself to it just um you know just
sort of be a sponge and sort of soak up
as much as you can ask questions
um
and
you know just sort of back yourself um
you know you probably hear loads of
horror stories coming into recruiting
about how difficult it is and it is
tough um but if you choose the right
company i mean ambition a great um
like you know you've got support of
supportive atmosphere um it's it's not
as i mean you know when you go into
recruitment you think it's going to be
super super sharky and everyone's going
to be nicking everyone's roles and
all that kind of stuff and i'm sure that
stuff probably does go on at some places
still but i mean and i can only talk
about my own experience at ambition
because you've got to choose the right
team um and the only way you can sort of
really figure that out is
look at glassdoor look at reviews speak
to people
within the firm interview there
and just choose the right firm um and i
think if you're if your company wants
you to do well you probably will do well
if you if you know you put the effort in
um yeah i think
she has a practical tips i'd say the
biggest thing for me is by actually
having the courage and
you know just be brave and pick up the
phone um and dahl a notoriously spiky
candidate or client that might be a bit
cold um like that's the hardest bit
picking up the phone and dialing yeah um
how did you work through it like how did
you get over that because i've i i can
remember that so that's to be fair it
still happens now sometimes when i'm
doing yeah business development you just
have that weird internal voice of like
oh you're gonna get rejected you're
gonna get rejected it's gonna go
terribly
i think the more you practice it the
better you get at it um
yeah and i've got a post-it note in
front in front of me that says
afraid of doing business development
question mark are you going to die
exactly what's the worst that can happen
yeah just like yeah you know don't take
yourself too seriously with it i think
um the worst thing they can do is say no
um or just be you know slightly uh
i've never really had this happen to me
but you know being i've heard it you
know be great you know aggressive with
you on the phone or whatever it is just
their loss kind of thing um you know
back yourself you're a good recruiter
you could have given them an excellent
candidate or opportunity so
brush it off move on um yeah yeah and
again i think that's where you it's like
yeah on this really quickly and then
i'll ask you the final question sorry
and i know when you when you we spoke
you said um
sometimes you'd like to go out the
office on that but i just want to ask
you because i've had this in my inbox
before and i definitely remember this so
i
when i went into recruitment it was a
team of eight people so obviously it was
just just literally obviously like a
bank of death rewards each other it's
obviously a small environment and i've
had people messaging me about this
before but like how did you get over
like
that worry of if people listening to
your calls
oh cause that was a real it's the right
hand i hated that you know what i did
you know when you leave a voicemail um
and you can press hash
to
re-record it yeah um so i was a bit well
i still am i guess but i was proper
proper perfectionist when i first
started i had to leave the perfect
voicemail um and if i didn't i pressed
hash and i just found so embarrassing
like come on get the voicemail right
first time and it's like you know if you
stop me words like you know call me on
or call me
mobile
and it's like
record i think i mean it's just yeah you
get over it i mean everyone's sort of
passed that you're in a room with like
you know ambitions probably about 30 of
us now um
in the office uh and everyone's if the
room's quiet and you know you're
speaking to a camp for the first time
and you're like you just gotta go for it
that is i think everyone struggles with
that um yeah yeah you do get over it
those as you get to know it more you
feel more comfortable in your own skin
within the office it's fine
yeah yeah it is it's like when it's
obviously it's harder when you're like
the new person you know what i mean it's
yeah when you're like when you're like
more embedded in the team than that it
like you don't you don't care it's just
funny because it's true like everyone
goes through that
um
love that so look final question
an important one why why should more
people consider recruitment as a career
rather than that just always being an
accidental courageous thing why should
people be choosing this as a career from
your experience so far
i think i mean i can only speak to
myself as an individual but i don't know
what other people's motivations are i'm
assuming that the financial side's a
huge thing for everyone but i guess
that's really well known
um so is the um i struggle with this
word merit meritocratic side of it yeah
i i struggle with that word there is a
correction
so yeah i guess that side i think that
was a massive thing for me personally um
i guess you know if you you know put in
the hard work
you know you get to a certain target
like you'll move up and progress you'll
be recognized for that within the
business
um so that's a massive thing
um and
i think you know
aside from um
all the sort of standard stuff ping pong
tables and incentives and all this
rubbish that sort of flying around you
know i guess the most important thing is
you're working at a people job if you
like working with people um not just
sort of you know clients and candidates
you know just in the office very social
um it's quite relaxed you know you can
have a laugh with people and it's it's
quite focused but friendly i think
that's how i describe it ambition at
least so i think if you want um
you know if you want a job where you
know you wake up and i'm not good like
you don't always wake up fully fully
excited for the day it's got something
really important going on but like
generally more times than not your buzz
into to get started
um and especially if you come into the
office and have a laugh
with you know people who become your
mates um
then
you know it's a fantastic career to
choose i think
i love it
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast thanks a lot being part of it
exciting
we're on another tour two years my man
thanks definitely
thanks very much